Amber Heard leaves an event due to a  serious emergency the 30 year old  actress attended the unite for Humanity  gala in Beverly Hills Friday night where  she was being honored for her  humanitarian work with the American  Civil Liberties Union when she abruptly  left before receiving the award  Amber's friends Cara Delevingne and IO  Tillett accepted the award on her behalf  according to E News IO explained the  Justice League stars departure while on  stage saying quote I've never seen amber  nervous and I've known her quite  intimately for a long time for her to  have to leave means that it was a very  serious emergency et has reached out to  herds reps for comment